[Music]
contagion or to demonic
Kiska to be fair I 170 square gamma
gamma Y so I'll use the on the dead
[Music]
at only 24 years old GFX today is aboard
a 30-foot boat sailing around the world
completely on his own know what
sensitive level 11 if you took a TV
effexor suit old Ramona found I won't
kidnap a kid iPad welcome sir
the chaplain Peter the Uncle Cap'n
Pearson he wears em sir as you can
accumulate can come in on the Stars say
Oh Josie vanilla he left his home in
France two and a half years ago to begin
his journey Geneva Devon Hispanic ready
Phil dr. yellow as you know Malik with
African in action evil okay Eva yeah
question I've ever known who is the
unknown vehicle if it's connected
passage in Oh West non-property the
Atlantic Parliament passes with fellow
partner on the drama of it olive oil is
Eva stamina also had the whole to of
course Shampoo past experience also a
mutiny
Miriam buku buku visa but the to sir
Messi is a genuine CMOS repair although
he's been navigating alone he's found an
unlikely companion she can occupy a
unique so heavy that I'm cool I don't
make the vibrato
not remittance anu o ke expert on a
melody impressive see alice kessane Papa
Panov oh man is it cool or cannery a
poor miserable Momo
Murphy honor of Alvin to German upon you
van sack doctor auto-da-fe to Alaska
mechanic nuni on ETO impressive our
commence a space probe our quarterly
Zambia profit motive a knowledge
situation typically t equal to t ozawa
SLR alternate arizona sativa on a ship
in on a class to dumansky to Jericho
[Music]
taxonomy second viento succeed mmm
DiMaggio don't remember to appear to be
[ __ ] Sunday Rocca Colonna a VAR lo
siento tu aura varsity Waverly kupuna
Olivia welcome Oscar when I go to
compete I'd realize there's not a lot of
people who look like me there's an
opportunity here to encourage and teach
people how to sail my name is Amy
Sinclair I'm a sailor and I'm trying to
open up sailing so that it's a more
diverse sport
[Music]
I got in the failing four years ago I
had a moment where I was just really
unhappy and the idea that I was able to
come out every Wednesday night and sail
with my teammates was like my one place
of like happiness and I loved that it
saved me when I was in a really dark
place the team that I raced with now is
called Sweet Caroline I love my
teammates they're my family
half the team is women we represent
eight different countries from Morocco
to Peru Jamaica to Colombia and India
but when I would go to compete I'd
realized we're the only team that looks
like us one of the things that I wanted
to do is start a collective channel
called sailing you are an Instagram
account so that I can get the word out
about it and encourage more people to
join it wound up taking off a lot of
people started following and reaching
out asking how they can learn I realized
that there's an opportunity here to
encourage and teach people how to sail
so then I started traveling I would put
together different groups of people and
we would go out and we would sail for a
couple days more recently I went to
Kenya I put together the first ever
women's sailing team and it was amazing
[Music]
I decided we're gonna start a women's
team we're gonna join this race and
we're gonna show these girls that they
can do this and help these girls feel
like they were empowered to learn
something new it was probably one of the
most amazing things I've ever
experienced in my life there were all
these women from this community who
never come out don't participate in
sailing or boating which is two of the
biggest drivers of the economy on that
island we changed the way a whole
community thinks about women's role in
society
I think sailing should be more inclusive
and diverse because it's such a loss
that other people don't get to
experience the same thing that I do it
they're just not used to seeing us so we
got to fix that I would say try
something new don't be afraid you'll
surprise yourself when you realize you
can do it and that feeling you can't put
a price on that
you
imagine you're a sailor working on a
Great Lakes freighter to two months at a
time
and you need your mail delivered well
that's where we commit my name is Jim
Hogan and I'm the owner and the fourth
generation of the JWST OTT company this
company was started in 1874 by my great
grandfather captain John Ward Westcott
we operate a shorter ship and ship to
shore delivery boat in the port of
Detroit
we're the only floating ZIP code in
actually the United States and it still
holds true today any package that's got
that four eight two two two zip code is
going to arrive here at our station on
any given day we receive the mail and
packages in the morning you see the
various pigeon holes as they were called
each of those represent different ships
we place mail in those slots and we wait
until the vessel is actually coming
through the port of Troy ok real good
let's see a little bit we packed the
mail bags
captain takes a vessel away from our
dock and off the midstream we go we
deliver mail by the pail and that's the
sailors mailbox if you will the crew men
aboard the ship will lower down a bucket
and we'll fill the bucket with the mail
and then we send a bucket back up
sometimes we're delivering passengers
crew we had a grocery order a number of
years ago the last item was about three
and a half feet long and I looked at it
it was a tuna a whole tuna we end the
delivery with a salute
we head back to the dock and wait for
our next adventure I've worked here for
43 years I'm grateful to have been a
part of all of this and I look forward
to fifth generation taking this on and
seeing where it goes up or down the
river as it were you get mixed emotions
when you're out there hunting the line
fish a feeling of accomplishment because
you're actually making a difference
a feeling of competitiveness because the
fact that in my case I'm trying to be
Florida's lionfish king lionfish are a
non-native species to the Atlantic the
Gulf and the Caribbean because they
reproduce at such a high rate and have
zero predators they are currently taking
over the waters here lionfish eat
basically everything that we eat which
includes crabs lobsters grouper flounder
anything you name it their game the
scary part is is that we don't know how
many of them are out there and it's
probably a lot bigger than we ever will
know because of the fact that we always
dive the public spots or the private
fisherman spots but I mean the ocean is
huge the lionfish challenge is a contest
set up for those of us that are making a
difference to go out and kill as many
lionfish as we can over the next four
months
not every person is a big fan of
spearfishing but the problem that we
have with the lionfish these things need
to be eliminated every one of them and
whether you're a big fan of it or not
this is just not about spearfishing is
about taking care of our ecosystem and
making sure that everything stays
balanced being crowned the lionfish king
wood will be a huge accomplishment but
it's not just about that the next
weekend I'll probably go out and do the
same thing again even though the
competition is over
[Music]